nous sommes un ensemble d'associer nous
avons le désir de travailler en commun
et nous avons le désir de faire quelque
chose qui plaît aux français une bonne
télévision qui plaisent aux français et
que répondez vous à vos détracteurs les
socialistes notamment qui menace de
présence je crois vraiment que ça c'est
un combat d'arrière-garde entièrement
périmés et qui n'a qu'une signification
aujourd'hui d'asseoir la démonstration
en tout cas a été faite que la cinquième
chaîne dans son tour de table actuelle
n'est pas une revanche elle est une
continuation
vous voulez apporter des garanties quant
au pluralisme de l'information par
exemple absolument réels mais le fait
même que ce tour de table soit pur alice
on va c'est notre désir de le lay
c'est bien du coni pourquoi vous êtes
vous associer à bessières centre à bord
était tellement sympathique on veut pas
perdre mon nom je me suis associé
rivière simple que je considère il ya
impossibilité
de faire ensemble une belle que vous
avez choisi la meilleure chance de
conserver votre chaise j'ai choisi la
chance de faire une prévision pour
missionnaire révision bien française de
vision tu peux gagner le pari de
l'audience